hey Vsauce Michael here if you through
every single human alive today into the
Grand Canyon we would not fill it up we
could make a pile about this big that's
it that's all of us all seven point one
five nine billion of us in one place a
species portrait it kind of puts
humanity in perspective and you so does
this every day you produce about one to
two liters of spit which means in your
entire lifetime all together you will
not produce enough spit to fill an
Olympic sized swimming pool so far five
hundred and sixty billion Lego parts
have been manufactured and the total
number of grains of sand on earth is
estimated to be 7.5 times 10 to the 18th
but here's the thing how many things are
there total well how do you define a
thing well let's say it's a thing if you
can think about it or talk about it if
you can call it a thing it's a thing
this is gonna be a lot of things things
can be real imaginary impossible ideas
are things things can be looked forward
to and things can be in the past or
yellow or concrete or abstract things
can happen and some things probably
won't making a video about how many
things there are no that's the thing
that I'm doing right now let's count
everything
right away the answer seems obvious the
word thing is so vague the answer is
clearly infinite possibly not all we
have to do is take the maximum number of
physical things things out there in the
real world beyond our minds we could in
theory measure and add to that the total
number of things we could imagine the
total number of thoughts possible for
the purposes of this video let's assume
that numbers and math and the laws of
physics exist as part of the way our
universe is but the names and
representations they've been given are
the products of thinking minds and those
things are well things that we can count
and there's no reason to double count
all of the indivisible pieces that make
up me particles or strings or whatever
are the same as the thing that has been
named me Abraham Lincoln has a great
quote about this how many legs does a
sheep have if you call its tail a leg
four because calling a tail a leg
doesn't make it one okay let's begin
when counting the number of physical
things in the universe we hit an unknown
how big is the universe the entire
universe could be infinite or it could
be finite but edgeless for a variety of
reasons there could also be other
universes but it's unclear whether we'll
ever be able to actually see all these
things instead what we are stuck with
and what we usually mean when we say the
universe is the observable universe
whose future visibility limit has been
estimated to be only sixty two billion
light years in any direction that's it
this is likely the only inventoriable
space we'll ever need to worry about
and it contains roughly on average 10 to
the 80 elementary particles particles
with no further internal parts as far as
we currently know
so that's our answer right there are 10
to the 80 physical things that exist out
there beyond our minds any other
physical thing water dogs planets
saxophones are just names given to
particular arrangements of those same 10
to the 80 particles but wait what if in
the future we discover that what we call
elementary particles today are actually
just made out of smaller things we
should have counted instead well to
cover ourselves let's count the maximum
possible number of the smallest
measurable thing something the size of a
Planck volume 10 ^ 183 things that small
could fit within our observable universe
I like this number 10 ^ 183 you couldn't
easily argue there were more things than
that in the physical real world but you
could imagine a Planck length the Planck
volume that's just the smallest
measurable amount of space not the
smallest possible you could imagine 1/2
plunk volume a ten thousandth of a
Planck volume but that would just be a
thought and only ever a thought so how
many possible thoughts are there it's
probably safe to say that the number of
possible thoughts is indeed infinite for
example numbers you can't say there's a
limit to the biggest number we can
imagine but unlike physical things that
exist whether or not we have discovered
them do unthought thoughts already exist
hmm it seems more like the pool of
possible thoughts is really just one
thing an actual elements from that set
don't become things by themselves until
we thing them that is we or some other
mind thinks about them or talks about
them and there's a limit to how many
things we or anything else could ever
thing our observable universe is only so
big and it will contain usable energy
for only so long
after about 1 trillion to a hundred
trillion years the supply of gas needed
to form new stars will be exhausted and
the lights will start going out one star
at a time after a googol years the
amount of usable energy left in the
universe will be zero and nothing will
be able to happen to calculate the
maximum number of thoughts that could be
thought inside our observable universe
let's take all of its mass and turn it
into human brains that just think new
and random thoughts from the beginning
of time until the universe runs out of
usable energy of Google years of
thinking but wait what if there are
alien brains or for all we know
earthling brains that think faster than
we can okay well to be safe let's not
turn all of that mass into human brains
let's use it to build a giant
hypothetical machine that computes at
the fastest speed possible given the
speed of light and the uncertainty
principle bruh mermans
limit its 1.36 times 10 to the 50 bits
per second per kilogram of material now
a high-end estimate for the total mass
of the observable universe is 3.4 times
10 to the 60 kilograms which used
exclusively for the best possible
computing machine could altogether
process 4.6 to 4 times 10 to the 110
bits per second
now with 3.15 4 times 10 to the 116
seconds available from the beginning of
time to the heat death of the universe
and an assumption that the average
thought takes about a sentence worth of
information to describe say about 800
bits we get a total of one point four
five eight times 10 to the 227 things
that could ever be thought or imagined
that number is huge in the observable
universe the universe as we will ever
know it the number of thoughts that can
be thought is so much larger than the
number of physical things there can be
without imagination and if you were to
combine the two totals the number of
physical things would barely make a
difference so funny enough when it comes
to everything in the universe it really
is the thought that counts and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]